- [laughing]
COOLIO, MAN.
OH, YEAH, "SOITAINLY."
OH, HEY,
I GOTTA GO.
YEAH, TERRY OUT.
- TERRY,
HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
- HEY, PRETTY GOOD,
GABE.
OH, GOT SOMETHING
ON YOUR SHIRT.
- NOT TODAY, TERRY.
- LOOKS LIKE GABE'S
COME OUT TO PLAY.
YOU DO HAVE SOMETHING
ON YOUR SHIRT, DUDE.
- NO, I DON'T.
- YEAH, YOU KIND OF DO.
- NO, I'M PRETTY SURE I DON'T.
- GOT A CLEAN SHIRT AT MY DESK
IF YOU WANT ME
TO GET IT FOR YOU.
- DON'T SEE WHY
THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY.
- BECAUSE THE SHIRT
YOU HAVE ON RIGHT NOW,
IT'S NOT CLEAN.
- EXCEPT FOR THAT IT IS.
- ME, I HAVE A CLEAN SHIRT.
- OH.
- YOU, YOU HAVE SOME SCHMUTZ
ON YOUR JAMMY-JAM.
- NO, THERE IS NO SCHMUTZ
ON MY JAMMY-JAM.
- YOKNOW WHAT?
WHY DON'T I JUST GET IT FOR YOU?
- YEAH, WHY DON'T YOU DO THAT?
- YEAH.
AND THERE WE GO.
- DID YOU GET IT?
- [laughing]
I ALMOST GOT YOU.
I WAS THAT CLOSE.
- ALMOST, YEAH.
- I MEAN, I'M THINKING,
"DAMN, HE'S GOOD."
[both laughing]
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE FUNNY THING IS?
- WHAT'S WHAT?
- NOW I GUESS FROM WHEN I DABBED
YOUR SHIRT
WITH THE PAPER TOWEL,
AND I'M NOT PLAYING
THE GAME RIGHT NOW,
BUT I ACTUALLY--I MUST HAVE GOT
SOME PAPER-TOWEL FUZZ
ON YOUR SHIRT, SO...
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
- HEY, HOW LONG HAS KAREN BEEN
WEARING HER HAIR UP LIKE THAT?
- I DON'T WANT YOU
TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT.
AND I'M SORRY
IT HAPPENED.
- HEY, TERRY,
WHAT'S GOING ON?
- UH, NOTHINING.
- HAVING A GOOD MORNING?
- YE--
- I'M HAVING A [bleep]
TERRIFIC MORNING.
- GREAT.
- HOPE THERE IS NOTHING
ON MY SHIRT.
'CAUSE
I CAN'T LOOK DOWN.
- OH, NO, DUDE, WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT RIGHT NOW, OKAY?
THERE'S NOTHING
ON YOUR SHIRT.
NO ONE CARES
ABOUT YOUR SHIRT.
EVERYTHING'S NOT
ABOUT YOU.
I'M TRYING TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION
WITH KAREN RIGHT NOW, SO...
- YOU OKAY, TERRY?
- IT JUST PISSES ME OFF.
[cell phone vibrates]
- [screams]
I GOT IT. I GOT IT.
THERE'S NO WAY--
OH, YEAH, YEAH,
I DO HAVE SCHMUTZ.
THERE'S SCHMUTZ
ALL OVER ME NOW.
HE CAN'T DENY THAT.
TERRY'S NOT GOING TO KNOW
WHAT HIT HIM.
[laughs]
I WILL WIN!
WHAT--
WHAT HAPPENED?
- TERRY DIED.
- I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
HEY, TERRY.
IT'S GABE.
I, UM--I JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT, UM...
THAT YOU DIDN'T GET ME, TERRY.
YOU DIDN'T GET ME,
BECAUSE ON THE DAY
THAT YOU DIED,
THERE WAS SCHMUTZ
ON MY SHIRT.
SO GUESS WHO WINS
THE GAME, TERRY.
I DO. I WIN.
[laughing]
YOU LOSE.
AAH!
[crying]
OH, TERRY.
HE FLICKED ME.